- [Instructor] In the last video,
we discussed why it took England
another 100 years to start colonizing
the New World after Christopher Columbus
first set foot in Hispaniola.
Among those reasons was conflict
within the United Kingdom,
colonial projects closer to home,
specifically Ireland,
and economic depression
that prevented England
from taking much time to
look outside its borders
to the broader world.
In this video, I'm gonna walk about
what led England to finally
get in the colonial game.
So what changes that allows England
to become a premier colonial empire
and go on to found what will be
the United States of America,
today even an English speaking country?
Well, some of these factors kind of
turn to their advantage.
Once the internal religious conflict
has been sorted out,
turning England into a Protestant nation,
they turn some of that animus outward
to Spain, a Catholic nation,
and they feel that they
have to compete with Spain
for riches
and for souls.
So certainly, the
Protestant nation of England
doesn't wanna be left behind
anymore than it already has been by Spain,
which has clearly been
reaping great riches
from the New World in the form of gold
down here in Mexico and Central America
and sugar, the Sugar Islands,
and they also don't wanna be one upped
by the Catholic nation of France,
which has been reaping
some excellent profits
trading with Native
Americans up in the region
which is today New York and Canada,
and they're getting furs.
So there's clearly a lot to be had
in the new world
and a lot of Catholics to
triumph over in having it.
Another thing that allows England to join
the imperial game in the New World
is the invention of the
Joint Stock Company.
Now, Joint Stock Companies
were kind of the precursor,
I mean, more than kind of the precursor,
really the precursor to
the modern day corporation,
and like modern day corporations,
what they did was kind of
spread both the riches and also the risk
of any kind of
entrepreneurial undertaking.
And what I mean by this is that
people could buy shares
in a Joint Stock Company,
and those shares were kind of divested
from your personal wealth.
So you could invest in something that,
if it went belly up,
wouldn't necessarily ruin you
'cause you just had a few shares.
So it's, you know, similar
to the stock market today,
a very early version of that.
So these Joint Stock Companies meant that
adventurers, people seeking wealth,
could go out to the
New World, for example,
with many different backers,
the risk spread across all of them,
and try to make profit
for their investors.
So many what we would call promoters
of the New World
tried to drum up interest in expeditions
to the New World.
Now, everybody knows that
Spain is making a killing
from gold and sugar,
and so they're saying, "Well,
maybe private individuals
"with the blessing,
though not the sponsorship
"of the crown can go to the New World
"and start extracting
some of these resources
"and start creating wealth
for their investors."
And so England issues several charters
to Joint Stock Companies that are still
familiar names to us today.
For example, the East India Company,
which Americans know best as the company
that supplied the tea
that Bostonians dumped
into Boston Harbor slightly
before the American Revolution,
but the one that plays the most role
in the early founding of the United States
is the Virginia Company,
and it's under the auspices
of the Virginia Company
that explorers like John
Smith head to Virginia
and Virginia is named
for Elizabeth the First,
Henry the Eighth's daughter,
who never married, and
therefore was said to be
the Virgin Queen,
so a new land named
after her was Virginia.
Now, we'll talk more
about the Virginia Company
in the next video,
but the last thing I wanna
say about what prompted
England to join the imperial
game in the New World
was that England was having
a serious economic depression
and some real poverty.
Now remember that England
was a highly classed society
with aristocracy and gentry,
and these were inherited roles, right?
You couldn't rise
to be among these ranks, generally.
So, you know, about 95% of the population
didn't belong to either of these groups,
and a strong majority of those
were in dire poverty in the 1500s
and early 1600s,
and there were a number
of reasons for this.
The market for wool, which England,
being a major textile
producer, had collapsed,
so many people who had been
wool producers were in dire straits.
In fact, many of them were Puritans,
and we'll see more about
what happens to the Puritans
who leave England in another video,
and there's a process going
on in this time period
known as enclosure,
the Enclosure Movement.
And what enclosure meant is
kind of what it sounds like,
which is that early English towns
and manor houses were
kind of set up to have,
you know, the house.
That's the big manor house,
so just bear with me and imagine here,
and then they might have some forest
filled with a nice deer to hunt,
and then they might have
some nice fields, just grass,
and these were kind of
considered common lands.
So if you were a peasant, for example,
you might graze your cows
on these common lands.
You might go hunting in the forest.
Well, in this time period,
these great English lords
started to close off,
enclose these common lands.
So they'd fence them off.
This kind of makes
sense to our modern idea
of property holding, right?
It makes us understand who owns what thing
and how it gets deeded, et cetera,
but for very poor people,
this was a huge transition
because now they didn't have a place
to raise their livestock.
They didn't have a source
of hunting, protein,
so it made people who
were already on the edge
of poverty extremely poor.
It was a very difficult time
if you were already kind of living
in the foraging or small farming aspect
of English life.
And so, because of this Enclosure
Movement and depression,
crime rates are going up in England,
and this is a time when theft
is still a capital crime.
So if you're starving and
you steal something to eat,
you could be hanged,
and so many of the English gentry,
the people in Parliament,
are looking around and saying,
"Alright, what's going on?
"Are we having a moral crisis?"
Because they don't think in terms
that say, "Alright, many people are poor.
"Maybe they're going to steal."
Instead, they're saying,
"Why are people stealing?
"What's wrong with people?"
And so they think of this
as surplus population,
say there are too many people in England.
Now this is patently untrue
because there are way more people
living in London today
than there were in all of
England at that time period,
but the English Parliament,
sort of major thinkers in England,
start to think that there are
too many people in England.
There are just too many people
for having enough stuff to go around,
and so they start wondering.
Maybe these people should go elsewhere.
Maybe they should go to colonies
where maybe they can buy more goods,
produce more raw materials,
and find a different place
in the social structure
and economy of England,
and that starts to come true
when the Virginia Company
sets off for Jamestown,
which they'll reach in 1607,
and we'll talk about
that in the next video.